hey hey how long does it drive up there
i want to time my edibles so it kicks in
right when we arrive
what nothing it's cool i'm not gonna
tell anybody i'm not a narc all right
you can tell people good because i'm a
narc i'm not a cop anymore and i have a
prescription for anxiety so it's legal
it'll be good for when all the drama
starts why do you think there's gonna be
drama oh no you're right whenever we go
on one of these group trips everything's
totally normal and there's never any big
conflict anyway i'm just gonna pop one
of these right now for no reason i'm not
looking
oh kevin what a surprise
why are you all in my house raymond
kevin what are you doing here
[Laughter]
my edibles just kicked in
just give it a shot they're already
separated it can't get any worse it's a
really good point thank you rosa she's
high as hell that's also a really good
point damn it rosa it's important to be
mindful of your energy when you're with
an infant trust me i'm sort of a natural
mother yeah natural mother
how long have you been there oh man i
have no idea
[Music]
oh
i think i just looked back in his room
what do i do oh sorry man i think the
second edible just kicked in and this is
a little too much for me also this is
not the vibe i was looking for
furrow i need your help no no no adios
amigo are there tools in here you see a
saw anywhere i told you stay away
charles i'm not into your energy
amy
hi
hi amy hi
look i just wanted to say thank you for
getting back to sleep
i was being really stubborn earlier and
i guess what i'm trying to say is
can i please have your nip tips you
don't want my nip tips those crusty old
things oh god i can't be here for this
oh my mouth is so dry it's all bad
what's all bad
i can't tell you baby what can't you
tell me it's too real i need to leave
damn it i was looking for someone to be
alone sorry i came out here looking for
a signal to call hitchcock but no luck i
can take my chips and go wait you have
chips
could stay oh okay
barbecue
sweet maui onion and this surprising
underdog
original i think i'm ready to crown a
champion champion that's good yeah i
came up with it because i misspoke
can i join you max never been asleep
this long and i don't know what to do
with myself charles locked your kid in
the room what you made me say if i
didn't you would have stayed here and
ruined this good thing i got going with
scully and his chips wait mac is locked
in a room oh no
we have an announcement we're here to
crown the winner of this year's great
tournament of chips rosa the champion is
smoky bacon chicken she's so high yeah
sounds pretty good though oh you guys
are duds scully and i are gonna bounce
hey rosa you want to take a couple days
off drive to buffalo see the warehouse
where sweet maui onion chips are
imported to unless you don't want to
hang out because you're not stoned
anymore actually buffalo sounds kind of
cool seriously that's just not the weed
talking oh no i'm not high at all
anymore oh no i was so high good news
while you were asleep we finally got
cell reception what's up cucks so how'd
everybody lose their v card i'll go
first amy was right drugs are bad
you